he forecast russia's invasion of ukraine
where most didn't think it would happen
and now ukraine's top military spy has
another prediction for how the war it
started will end
up close and scrutinize their moves and
goes further russia's defeat he says
will be disastrous for both its leader
and his country
that does mean a politician
he is
rumors about putin's ill health he says
are confirmed by ukrainian
russia is suffering huge losses the
general says an entire battalion wiped
out trying to cross this river in
donetsk
and in the area around hakeev its forces
push back almost to the russian border
russia's much-vaunted modernized
military has proved itself a myth in
ukraine he says whatever image it likes
to project
can we don't know
[Music]
is
we are in an information war propaganda
spewed by both sides but this is the
first time a senior official here has
said when the war will end a sign of
growing confidence their enemy will be
beaten what are your feelings now my
feelings now yeah
optimistic
dominic waghorn sky news cleave